THIS IS AMERICA IN 2019.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE SAYING
NOTHING ABOUT THIS OF COURSE.
BRENDAN SHOCKLEY JOINS US HERE
TONIGHT PRAYED THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON AND TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHERE YOU WERE, AND WHAT THESE
PEOPLE’S IDEA?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
TUCKER.
I WAS A GUEST LAST NIGHT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR THE CLOSE OF THE
RNC CONVENTION TO WATCH THE
SPEECH.
IT WAS A MAGICAL EVENING AND
EVERYTHING WAS INCREDIBLE LIKE
SOMETHING OUT OF A STORYBOOK.
I WAS THERE WITH A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE FROM MY ORGANIZATION.
AS I WAS LEAVING WITH TWO PEOPLE
THE FELLOW MAN AND CONSERVATIVE
ACTIVIST, WE WERE EXITING THE
CONVENTION ALONG WITH A LARGE
GROUP OF PEOPLE, AND THERE WAS A
SMALL GROUP OF BLM HECKLERS THEY
ARE TO HARASS PEOPLE AS THEY
WERE WALKING OUT.
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
EXITING WENT TO THE RIGHT, THE
TWO FRIENDS OF MINE AND I EXITED
AND WE WENT TO THE LEFT WHICH
WAS A BIG MISTAKE.
WE WERE TRYING TO GET BACK TO
OUR HOTEL AND AS WERE WALKING
BACK TO OUR HOTEL, FOUR OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE WITH THE BLM MOB
THAT WAS HARASSING THE MAJORITY
OF THE PEOPLE AS THEY WERE
LEAVING, WAS WALKING DOWN THE
STREET, CROSSING US AS WE WERE
WALKING BACK TO THE HOTEL.
THAT’S WHEN THEY STARTED HURLING
HOMOPHOBIC SLURS AT US COMING
ANTI- GAY  SLURS PRAYED.
THEY THREW A DRINK AT ME AT CUP
IN MY FACE AND THEY AND THEY HIT
LIBBY ALBERT, THE GIRL THAT WAS
WITH ME.
THEY CALLED US THE ANTI- EFFORT
ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE TIMES AS YOU
CAN SEE IN THAT VIDEO.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, TUCKER,
I HAVE ENDURED ANTI-GAY ATTACKS
LIKE THIS AT SEVERAL TIMES IN MY
LIFE.
IT’S BEEN AT LEAST TEN YEARS AND
SENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN.
WHAT MADE THIS BILL DIFFERENT AS
THAT THIS TIME THE ATTACKERS GET
TO PORTRAY THEMSELVES AS THE
VICTIMS.
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN WE WOULD
ENDURE HOMOPHOBIC ATTACKS, AT
LEAST THEY DIDN’T HAVE THE TO
SAY THAT THEY WERE THE VICTIMS.
>> THAT IS SUCH A GOOD POINT.
TO ALTHOUGH WELL-MEANING RICH
LADIES WITH BLM SIGNS ON THEIR
FRONT LAWNS.
AND ALL THE HR DEPARTMENTS
ALLOCATING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO BLM, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THEM?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS A
GROUP THAT JUST ATTACKED TWO GAY
PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE A DANGEROUS GROUP.
IF I MAY SAY QUICKLY TOO BECAUSE
YOU BROUGHT UP THAT WAY THE
MEDIA COVERED THAT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK SOME OF THOSE IN
MEDIA, PEOPLE LIKE ANDERSON
COOPER, DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
SAY ABOUT THE FACT THAT TWO MEN
WERE ATTACKED LAST NIGHT BY
BLACK LIVES MATTER BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
ORGANIZATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK THAT TWO PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY WERE ATTACKED BY THIS